hello I haven't done anything stupid in
a while so I'm gonna do something stupid
today if you're a fan of the kind of
stuff that I do here on the Charlie is
so cool like YouTube channel have you
ever felt the need to consolidate
everything you like about the YouTube
channel into one milkshake okay like a
milkshake well of course you haven't but
it's a great idea isn't it so we should
do that I don't expect you actually
going to want to make this milkshake
it's probably gonna be quite disgusting
but apparently people like so watch me
do disgusting things on YouTube so here
we go if you wanna make the Charlie
shake here's what you're gonna need a
packet of wine gums from the video that
I made called the wine gum experiment so
tomato ketchup from the time I tried to
drink an entire bottle of tomato ketchup
and failed miserably some marshmallows
from the video are except a bunch of
marshmallows in my mouth some cinnamon
from the time I did the cinnamon
challenge or at least tried to
some fish fingers and some custard from
the time that I tried to eat fish
fingers and custard and it was actually
kind of nice a cup of tea from that
really really old video where I made tea
or whatever and finally to make it a
milkshake some ice cream and some milk
you'll also need a blender so you can
blend blend
first the wine gums then the ketchup how
much ketchup you want to put in
completely depends on how disgusting you
want it to be and the marshmallows I'm
using flumps but any marshmallows will
do then the cinnamon this order by the
way that I'm putting in everything is
very important so make sure you get it
right that was a lot of cinnamon then
the effusive you guys make sure you put
these in one at a time just for added
offense custard yeah then the tea and
last but not least the milk and the ice
cream to make it a milkshake it looks so
gross it looks so gross let's go in for
the close-up look at that ready okay
right okay I think that's just good as
we get again yeah yeah it doesn't smell
that bad widly okay at least I know how
to make milkshakes now if nothing else
initially it tastes a bit weird cuz
there's a little bits of like fish or
something just kind of in the texture
then it's not so tastes a bit like
cinnamon and it's like oh this actually
isn't that bad and then suddenly you get
the kind of rush of ketchup and it's
just I mean it's all good stuff all good
stuff in there and it's all been cooked
fine so I mean what's the problem
I'm afraid about what little bits and
bobs might be sitting there on the
bottom so this is probably gonna be the
words bit Alex has agreed to have some
my flatmate Alex is it wrong that I like
it I mean it does make me feel gross to
drink here I'm probably gonna finish
this but then I won't have any more yeah
thank you for being part well there you
go the Charlie milkshake or the charlie
take I forgot what I called it that's
all see you next time
or something you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
yes I'm very aware of the fact that I
need a haircut you don't need to tell me
thank you
look milkshakes coming back up